joining us here on the rich eisen show
for the first time um and um i'm pleased
to have him here talking about march
madness
uh cbs basketball insider of uh again
college basketball insider of cbs sports
and the host of the college hoops today
podcast joining us in the middle very
busy time of march madness john
rothstein how you doing john
good great to be with you man yep you
got it so uh what's the story of this
tournament right now what's what do you
consider the story of this tournament
right now shaheen
the saint peter peacocks a run i think
that you can say when you split the atom
rich might be more impressive than umbc
beating virginia in 2018 when you look
at that upset for umbc deandre honor who
was an integral part of virginia winning
a national championship in 2019 was
unavailable to play during that run
because of an injury you look at st
peters and the limited resources that
this program has being in the heart of
jersey city being undermanned rich i
remember when saint peter's last went to
the ncaa tournament in 2011 they had two
full-time assistants and the third
assistant was only able to take the job
because he had a pension from the united
states air force and for that team to go
toe-to-toe with kentucky and then
beat murray state has seen that 130 game
from wire to wire in the round of 32.
this to me is one of the miraculous runs
that we've seen in the history of the
greatest event in sports so then the
question is though is how much further
do you think they can go that's the
magic question right
well i think you know i think obviously
every game that we see them win will be
a surprise from here on out i think the
one thing that you know you obviously
have to evaluate when you see a team
from a mid major level is how are they
going to match up with guys who have
certain size on the front line kentucky
obviously at oscar sheebway but the size
and the girth of purdue up front with
zac edie and trayvon williams i believe
will be the end of the line this week in
philadelphia okay so then uh which team
do you think is a low seed has the best
chance to go on a more magical run than
the one that st peters is on right miami
because of guard playing you know rich
you know this is our first time chatting
but you know since we're gonna you know
empty the bucket right now i am a big
big rocky fan and you remember in rocky
three when apollo creed talked to rocky
after he lost the clubber lane he said
the way to get it back is to go back to
the beginning when jim larinega first
built miami's program he built a program
based on getting transfers sitting them
out registering him and being older than
everybody else miami answer has some
success dabbled in with elite high
school players guys like ronnie walker
bruce brown obviously they've done a
really really good job as well you know
with guys you know who are on the team
right now from the high school front
like isaiah wong but the makeup of this
team with charlie moore with cameron
gusty is about experience and age miami
rich starts three 50-year seniors a lot
like apollo priest at the rocky way to
get it back is to go back to the
beginning look at you man i like it can
can you lace the rest of your commentary
in the few minutes i have left with you
here with every other rocky film too
john can you do something i mean if you
want to extend it you know until the
games start on thursday i can come back
tomorrow and wednesday you know i mean
what we can get together no i know
i think of it well i mean i guess we
should stick with phil uh philadelphia
then villanova against my alma mater
michigan um
is villanova or or duke
or you know because now auburn's already
out and now st peters took care of the
other two seed which two-seed do you
think has got a better chance duke or
villanova to go on a run here they both
have equally difficult tasks and i
picked arizona and gonzaga to meet the
national championship game but i'll say
this rich when you look at this ncaa
tournament from 30 000 feet it's the
polar opposite of last year's tournament
last year we knew
we knew from the start that there were
two teams better than everybody else
baylor on one side gonzaga on the other
side look right now at the level of
separation and how minimal it is between
teams in this tournament the one seed
baylor's out they lost north carolina
kansas took on a creighton team that
didn't have ryan paul brenner its best
shot blocker and didn't have ryan
memphis the big east correction of the
year who was lost for the season a
couple of years ago with a wrist injury
and it was in a possession game against
creighton then you look at arizona they
limp out of the game against tcu which
was the game of the tournament so far
thanks to the greatness and the
unbelievable shot-making ability of ben
matheran a player in this tournament who
i thought before the game started would
explode like a volcano in the ncaa
tournament rich last night we started to
feel the lava and gonzaga was able to
come back against memphis in the round
of 32. those are your four number one
seeds it wouldn't shock me if we see
less than three of them reach the final
four coming up in new orleans cbs's john
rothstein here on the rich eisen show uh
you mentioned uh mather and ben matheran
of arizona uh spectacular i i mean you
know obviously i'm not going out on a
limb he's a pac-12 player of the year
that said there were so many officiating
moments in that game and i i go back and
forth on the subject matter because you
got to play better than the refs ref in
every
endeavor in sports john but i don't know
if it's because we're seeing so much
basketball in a span of four days or the
fact that um there is four days worth of
basketball and good luck trying to get
uh the same uh consistency of
officiating with all of those games
trying to be played is there an
officiating issue with ncaa basketball
right now i don't know if there's an
official appreciating you but i'll say
this
the officiating has been very poor in
the ncaa tournament it was abominable in
the north carolina baylor game yeah the
technical foul on rj melendez in the
illinois houston game was a miscarriage
of justice and what happened last night
to pretty much bow out at the end of
regulation
okay in the arizona tcu game which again
was the the game of the tournament was
another miscarriage of justice just
waiting for somebody else to decide the
game and they are very very fortunate
that dale and terry's shot happened
after the buzzer went off in the game
with the sign in overtime because it
would have been an embarrassment that
didn't last for years it would last for
decades yeah why did the clock stop for
a split second like what's the ex what's
the reasoning on that john you know i
don't i don't know the answer to that
question rich all i just know is that
you know immediately after that
situation you know again we're just
talking for the first time you know
maybe the next time i'm out in l.a i can
text you you know we can grab a heineken
light somewhere i don't know if you're a
light guy or a gas guy or a craft guy
but we're working through this
friendship
just for the record i think it's going
quite well i think so all i know is this
i call my parents after the game i'm 38
and a half i said you know i have to
tell you for the first time in decades
four decades i'm almost speechless well
i'm a red wine guy by the way john i've
never had a glass of wine you know so um
okay so uh again i know you got uh you
know a limited amount of time because
you're working on stories you're
breaking stuff i like it um so uh i
guess which
which give me give me give me the team
that can actually crack the the national
championship game i know you said miami
could go on a run and you think that
it's going to be arizona and gonzaga but
give me one that you think can actually
crash it
the whole thing it's a great question i
think that this has been a final four or
bus type season all year for purdue
and i think when you look at the
chemical makeup of this produced scene
and the bracket that has opened up for
them in the east region you have the one
seed baler out you have the kentucky
seeds the num assuming the compositino
the number two seed they're out of the
bracket right now things are aligned for
baylor to get to the first shooting for
purdue to get to the first time
for purdue to get to the final four for
the first time since 1980 but i also
look on the bottom right of your bracket
and i see the region of vulnerability
kansas is a vintage kansas we have a 10
and an 11 going against each other in
miami and iowa state and then you have a
providence team that is in the second
week of the ncaa tournament for the
first time since 1997
when providence had the ball at the end
of regulation against the eventual
national champion arizona wildcats under
pete dillon and lost the game in
overtime so i look at that bottom right
as being the region of vulnerability i
still believe obviously in arizona and
gonzaga and then you know you look at
the makeup of that bottom left region
you got two great brands going against
each other in north carolina and ucla
and then you've got your traditional
david vs goliath showdown purdue against
st peters in philadelphia the door is
open for purdue right now again to get
to the final four for the first time
since 1980 matt painter has been his
best
several times during his career in west
lafayette this is his best chance to get
there all right so i guess uh before i
let you go uh let me try my hand at a
rocky analogy for you john
um how about uh michigan head coach
juwan howard going from uh rocky iv i
will break you in the handshake line to
i guess whether it be rocky one you know
uh uh hugging uh somebody consoling them
crying uh like in the handshake line uh
in dispatching with tennessee how about
how about the turnaround for my coach
about that one is impressive he's a
mensch it sounds like you're a mitch too
but i've never had a glass of wine
okay did i go to this glass of wine i've
never played golf i've never had a cup
of coffee and i've never been to europe
but i'm going to europe uh this summer
that's the plan okay johnny got married
i suppose fam postponed my wedding twice
to the pandemics they were supposed to
go to europe uh july into august so
maybe you know you can get my number
from the beer so you can give me a
couple of uh ideas i'm happy to do that
john
what summer camp did you go to it sounds
like i went to summer camp with you joan
what summer camp no my uh my father ran
a camp and my mother uh did arts and
crafts so uh you know that was how we
got you know family time at the end i
just didn't ran a camp for uh a year
there's no jewish people in new york
there's no jewish geography to play with
you right now is that what you're saying
john you just gotta run because you
gotta you're breaking the story right
now it's a new oh
all right take care of yourself john
we'll tell you we'll chat
there's john rothschi
i like him is he keeper uh he's a keeper
yeah i like him he's fun a rocky three
reference come on he's one of us i made
a rocky iv
i watched you far back that was nice hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here